I want to give you a little Ireland trip update.
Daniel is getting very good at driving
on the opposite side of the road.
We went to a farmer's market this morning,
and I found a vendor that was selling her homemade water kipper.
And this is her beetroot version,
which was so earthy and delicious.
I loved it. We also went on a walk to the cliffs of Bali cotton,
and we walked along the path.
It was there. It was breathtakingly beautiful.
We all loved it so much. The air.
The ocean air was so moist and humid,
and honestly, I love humidity so much,
but it was beautiful. Um,
Fran, for some reason,
here in Ireland, her hair is looking so red.
Daniel was looking like Mr.
Darcy in that last clip, so I had to take a video.
And we watched the sunset on the cliffs. It was so.